I was watching Chicago med sure and then  I hit the button from the makers of  Chicago Fire in Chicago PD if you're an  actor from Chicago who can't get on one  of these shows it's time to hang it up  I'd better get in here he had a brat  oh boy oh boy up get the cheese in here  this fella needs cheese stick  yeah then I was watching family feud for  oh my goodness  and then I hit the button fat folks  answer easy questions what happens why  is he wearing a suit for this show well  I better get stuff for the Varia no I  get the whole family talking about juicy  farts no I know apparently offered to  remember when we want even know a vision  yeah remember when I was uh I used to  think that was an achievement  now something if you if you're on  television by definition you're an  [ __ ]  well you kids should just go  [Music]  you